Thank you very much.
So yeah, so like he said, we'll be talking about next-gen
MSPs and how partners
can move from being just maybe a reseller,
a service provider, all the way to
become strategic partners.
So if we go ahead and we go to the next slide
here, we can see the agenda.
We'll be going through a few high-level things at the
beginning like the definition, maturity
model, uh, but we'll also have some call
to actions in here as well.
So AWS, let's start with the basics.
This is how we define managed services,
and it's as the engagement when the partner
is actively managing AWS
accounts, services, and workloads
on the customer behalf
and providing them with 24/7 management
and support.
And when we look at most of our partners
across the ecos across the
uh industry, we see lots of different
partners break into different areas.
We have the full stack managed service
provider, but we also have the generalist
managed service provider.
And usually when we see these full
stack managed service providers, they
started at that generous level.
Then they started adding 123
things in the full stack area.
Then all of a sudden they can do everything in the full stack
level and they still maintain
and say that the generalist level basically
becomes table stakes. It's just something
they have to do and they don't even really
talk about it anymore.
They're talking about their differentiate offerings, their
industry offerings, their sustainability offerings.
And this ties directly with our customer
needs.
When we look at what customers say, they
say that they are looking for trusted advisors
and by generating these long term agreements
with your customers and really building
trust, you as an MSP become
that trusted advisor.
They also build everything secure
from the very beginning.
Everything is scalable from the very beginning.
They have the technical mastery so that customers
can ask them any questions and they'll quickly
get an answer.
And then finally they provide that comprehensive
protection that can keep customers for a long
period of time and allow them to
actually come to you and
feel comfortable asking and getting improvements
and changes.
When we look at specifically workloads
on the MSP front,
we see a drastic change
and growth when it comes to those
workloads.
First, an MSP joins the picture.
There's a brief stabilization period
that you can see at the beginning,
where maybe the MSP reconfigures things,
find out the customer bought wrong things,
things might not have been configured correctly.
After that, that's the first period of
earning trust with that customer.
We now see a period of growth
that can be, OK, now let's scale things up,
let's get new workloads.
Now, they'll go and continuously optimize.
So once again, there's another reduction in
spend from that customer standpoint,
so they can earn trust once again with that
customer. Then they
reach operationalized steady state
where now ideally they're spending the exact
right amount
and now they can go and win another workload
at that same customer.
So they continually do this, they continually
improve these customers' organizations,
basically one workload at a time.
And so when we look at our MSP maturity
model, it's a structured framework that will
assess the benchmarks, capabilities,
and performances of the partner.
And it's really important because it allows
us to create curated enablement.
We've worked with lots of different leaders across
the organization. We've worked with lots of technical
folks to create dedicated enablement
for partners in the different stages.
We also can clearly align benefits
to each one of these stages,
and it helps us more easily validate
partners,
ideally identify where they
are and provide them with the just in time
resources that they need.
So when we look at the maturity model stages,
there's 5 of them. It starts with the early
basic cloud reseller, and it goes
all the way to the strategic partners,
GSIs, who are focused on that digital
transformation and consulting.
We'll dive a little bit deeper into each one of these,
with the first being that early or that
basic cloud reseller.
They have that ability to do capacity resell.
They do basic account management, billing
support. They don't have any pure
play managed services.
They probably do resold support. Maybe
they have one person on the support side
that can answer questions for them.
And really what they're looking for to move
to that next stage is they need
to start creating that business plan.
Train your team,
build a cloud ops team,
finalize your support offerings on top
of resale.
Start hiring a couple of people that can answer
those questions.
Define what your actual target
segment and positioning is
because then that will help you with all of these
different areas.
So we all of these different maturity
stages that you'll see are defined
and broken down into really these four
areas that you can focus on as a business
to move up to the next stage.
So some key performance indicators
that early stage partners are probably
looking for to move to that emerging
stage that you can track, define, and measure
is what's your AC engagement rate.
So you need to build, maintain your
opportunity pipeline.
As you're going and creating new offerings,
make sure those new offerings are in AWS.
Launch those opportunities, share those details
because then you'll start coming up for more
service level engagements rather than just the resell
engagements.
You as a company should also be looking at what
number of customers have you transitioned? Have
you got them on some sort of basic support
package? Have you got them on basic managed
services?
And then from a customer satisfaction standpoint,
what we see as partners go up
this maturity model is their satisfaction
rates go up, their retention rates go up.
So it's very, very important that you're tracking these
as well to ensure that you're doing the right things.
The next one is the emerging. This is really
the reseller that has support services
or lightweight services.
So of course they still have that capability to do
the resell,
but now they've gone as far as gotten a
service offering foundational technical
review approved.
So they have that validation from AWS.
They have limited support services,
primarily we see it around backup,
disaster recovery,
firewall security.
And it becomes about a transaction-based
relationship. We're gonna go, we're gonna
bring you on board, we'll get you everything
set up, and now we're gonna stand back and
we're gonna let you call us if any problems actually
come up. What
we want to see as you're moving up
to the next stage is actually expanding
to a horizontal support
model, actually going and
starting to build some automation and tooling.
If you don't build the automation
tooling at this level, you're gonna continually
struggle as you move up the stack.
As you get more customers, more complicated
customers, you are going to struggle
being able to handle that number of tickets
that you'll get
or those solutions that need to be done.
And then continue with the staff development.
Maybe those people in the beginning were just doing
those level one tickets. This is an
opportunity that you can begin upskilling them.
We have a AWS managed services
training course now
with a badge that partners can have
and take and use it to upskill
their teams and have them grow to be
ready to provide those extra level of services.
When we're looking at KPIs from this standpoint,
we start looking at now what does
your managed services revenue look
like? What sort of customers
do you have on a recurring revenue stream
instead of maybe a yearly revenue stream?
What sort of service adoption and coverage
do you have?
Are you going upselling customers from
maybe your basic package to now your
services package?
And then of course maintain the operation
side of the business so you're prepared as
you continue to gain more customers.
If your SLAs start to suffer,
you need to figure that process out.
You need to automate more things.
So it's very, very important that all of these
different levers are balanced so you're
prepared to continually grow your business.
Then we move to the established
and the and the established partners
are services partners with a horizontal
based managed services offering
so to work across all industries primarily
focused on infrastructure
and this is when customers start
feeling like the MSP is
their own IT shop.
You are an extension of their business,
and this is where we really start seeing
the retention rates increase.
They have well-defined automation. They
have well-defined ITSM processes.
And these are the partners that we look for
that are in our managed service provider
program today.
As you're moving up, this is what we're
looking for. We're looking for partners to start
adding things like Gen AI data
and analytics.
We want them to deepen their automation.
We want them to start thinking about
industry, vertical solutions,
where is your customer base that you've acquired
so far? Double down, triple
down in those areas and start developing
specific offerings for that.
Then also specialize in industry regulations.
Industry regulations is very, very
complicated, and depending on the segment
that you're working with, this can be an
extremely large value add to help them navigate
that regulatory environment
and then ultimately offer
compliance as a service to those customers.
When we move into this area, we're looking at
how can you expand the service portfolio,
how much are you leveraging AI and
automation,
and how well are you upskilling
your talent,
because at this level you want to continually
upskill so you're always on the forefront
of technology.
The last thing that you want is when you're building
that trusted advisor relationship with your
customers,
something new comes out, they call and
they want it and you say, we don't know how to do that.
That's the last thing that you want because now
that customer will start going and looking
for someone that can, and then that can be
a slippery slope where they start moving
everything to them.
So that upskilling of talent is extremely,
extremely important.
And the final one is the market leader.
And the market leader typically goes to market
with a solution-based approach.
They have cloud native development,
they do management of business
applications, and they can fully
handle governance, risk, and compliance.
And so they really are transforming
into a full level or full stack
MSP
where they can create tailored solutions for industries.
They co-innovate with AWS.
They really shape the industry direction
with AWS
and they even start moving into areas
like sustainability, green IT
solutions,
and they continue to push their market
leadership through those white papers and best
practices.
For the market leader
partners, we're looking at them to
go and show us their digital transformation
impact. How many strategic
digital projects have you done?
What does your industry and vertical solution
strategy, specialization look like?
And also we're looking at innovation and
IP creation.
How much are you reinvesting as a company
to go and develop new solutions, new
areas,
uh, new modernization techniques, and
new AI techniques?
Then, sorry,
I actually I have one more, the strategic, the strategic
is the industry technology partners
or the GSI's
who go a step further in that
industry thought leadership, and they have
a global reach and global
delivery capabilities.
They focus on outcome-based engagements
rather than just 1 to 1 or
service level baseline engagements.
They actually go up above and beyond and establish
these innovation labs. They invest heavily in
ROI R&D.
They partner directly with the C-suite to
guide the transformation strategy,
and they maintain a robust pipeline
of customer case studies across all
of the different industries.
And this is all important because what
we see is we see that profitability
increases as you move up each of
these stages.
So MSP revenue really does
grow with this advancement.
So starting with that baseline generalist,
we actually see about $2.50
revenue multiplier
for those generalist MSPs,
and they earn about 25 to 30%
gross profit.
As you move up to that next gen MSP,
we now see them start unlocking a
$4.90
revenue multiplier or 55%
gross profit.
So going and moving up that stack
is very, very integral for your
business to be able to
provide you that foundation to say this is
what we're working toward and tell business
leaders this is what we're going to unlock
once we have these capabilities, and
this is why we should invest in there.
And we actually partnered with a
BCG consulting group
and we created an ROI assessment
tool that can help partners like yourself determine
where you are
and this data comes from them on why
investing in AWS MSP capabilities
is one of the most financially attractive opportunities
for partners in the services market.
Our analysis shows that approximately,
oops. Our analysis
shows that our participants
received about a 3 to 4 times return
on investment over 5 years.
So that ROI was really
driven because of the recurring revenue streams
that they unlocked,
the automation efficiencies that they unlocked.
And what's particularly attractive is the 2
to 3 year payback period,
meaning that you'll see positive returns
well before the 5 year mark.
And so as you can see here, we
also see long term value created,
we see the valuation range, so we
have lots of good data that all can be
leveraged when you're having those C-level
conversations about why we need to invest
and change and grow into an MSP
partner
and a couple that, like I mentioned, we have a
uh analysis tool that can also help
you with this.
Let me leave you with 3 concrete
steps to accelerate your NP journey with AWS.
First,
go ahead and assess your current state.
Whether you're just starting out or you're
already established, you need to
clearly understand exactly
where you are in your MSP journey.
This isn't about just checking boxes. It's not
about lying or cheating on the test
to make yourself look better
for your C level. It's about understanding
clearly where you are so you have a
place to go in the future.
Next, invest in their future.
Once you identify what your stage
is, build an investment plan.
Decide how much we're going to invest, where
we wanna be in 3 to 5 years,
and we can help you on that journey
as well on what different components
we need to help you. We can provide you
resources,
and it could mean anything from developing new capabilities,
upskilling your current team,
hiring new people,
but every dollar invested
should align with your growth strategy.
Then finally connect with the AWS MSP
team. We have things like accelerated
MSP build workshop. We have other
resources that can leverage.
I'm here.
Bapa is back there, our technical lead,
so we're both here that we can help out with any
questions that you might have.
Thank you very much and I'll be around as well for
any other questions that you might have.